just like a ferrari every part of
bigquery was designed to make your
queries run
fast and that includes bigquery's
managed storage
in today's episode we're going under the
hood to figure out exactly how
bigquery stores this data so that you
can make informed decisions
on how to optimize your bigquery storage
[Music]
when talking about bigquery storage
there are a few things
i always like to point out first off
bigquery offers fully managed storage
meaning you don't have to worry about
provisioning servers
or worry about configuring any hardware
all sizing is done automatically
and you only pay for what you use next
bigquery uses what we call columnar
datastore
taking a step back for a moment
traditional relational databases
like postgres and mysql store data
row by row in record-oriented storage
this makes them really good at
transactional updates
for example changing the status of an
order because they
only need to open up a single row to
read or write data
however if you want to perform an
aggregation
like summing up the sale price column to
get your total revenue
you would need to read the entire table
into memory
bigquery on the other hand uses columnar
storage
where data is co-located by column
rather than row
this makes bigquery an ideal solution
for analytical use cases
now to calculate the total revenue
bigquery will only need to read in the
sale price column
internally bigquery stores data in a
proprietary columnar format
called capacitor one really cool thing
about capacitor
is that it uses relevant factors like
the type of data
and how the data is being used to
reshuffle rows and encode columns
one example is run length encoding
let's pretend that the value 1 appears
three times in a row
in your data rather than storing 1 1
1 capacitor can instead store 1
3. but what if the rows are ordered such
that there are no long runs of the same
value
well to solve this capacitor simply
reorders the rows
to obtain a compact encoding
so now we know about bigquery's file
format
but where do these files actually get
saved
the persistence layer for bigquery is
provided by the distributed file system
throughout google colossus colossus has
a ton of disks that live on a ton of
servers
but when you have so many chances are
that dozens of disks are going to fail
each day
so the goal is to make sure that no data
is lost
colossus ensures durability by using
something called erasure encoding
which breaks data into fragments and
saves redundant pieces across a set of
different disks
however to ensure the data is both
durable and
available the data is also replicated to
another availability zone
within the same region that was
designated when you created your data
set
this means data is saved in a bunch of
different buildings
that has a different power system and
network
the chances of multiple availability
zones going offline
at once is very small but
if you use multi-region locations like
the us
or the eu bigquery stores another copy
of the data
in an off-region replica that way the
data is recoverable
in the event of a major disaster
aside from replication colossus also
protects your data by ensuring that it
is 100
encrypted at rest plus
if you want to control encryption
yourself you can use
customer managed encryption keys
and the great thing about all of this is
that encoding
encryption and replication are included
in the price of bigquery storage
so no hidden costs so far
we've talked about the format in which
bigquery stores data
and we've talked about the physical file
system where the data is stored
but how do we ensure that data is stored
in a way that makes our queries as
performant as possible
bigquery has a storage optimizer that
helps arrange data
into the optimal shape for querying by
periodically rewriting files
files may be written first in a format
that is fast to write to
but later bigquery will format them in a
way that's fast to query
aside from the optimization happening
behind the scenes
there are also a few things that you can
do to further enhance storage
first off bigquery allows you to
partition your table
when it's created partitioning basically
allows you to divide
large tables into smaller chunks or
partitions
which are stored in a physically
separate location
when you include a where clause in your
query bigquery will only need to read in
the partitions
that you actually need bigquery allows
you to partition data
based on the time it was ingested a date
column
with granularity as low as hourly or
an integer column when deciding on
partitions you should consider
how people at your organization are
using this data
for example if data consumers are most
often looking at
orders placed in the past week it might
make sense to partition your table by
order date
so that you can efficiently read data
just from the past seven days
partitions are designed for places where
there is a large amount of data
and a low number of distinct values
a good rule of thumb is making sure
partitions are greater than one gigabyte
if you over partition your tables you'll
create a lot of metadata
which means that reading in lots of
partitions may actually slow down your
query
if you need higher cardinality or you
have a smaller table
you should use clustering clustering is
like sorting your tables on a particular
set of columns
for example clustering our table by
customer id
would sort the rows based on the
customer id
in bigquery you're able to choose up to
four columns to cluster on
this allows for efficient lookups
because the query engine
needs to open files that have the
cluster key
for example if we query our table and
include a filter
to only look at orders placed by
customer number one
then we only need to open up this file
the tricky part of clustering is
maintaining the clusters when the data
is changing
but bigquery sells this by periodically
re-clustering each table
this happens automatically without any
user intervention
or additional cost partitioning and
clustering are often used together
we can partition by the low cardinality
field for example
the created date of the order and
cluster by the high cardinality one
like customer id this lets you operate
over a date range slice of the table
but it also lets you find records from a
particular customer
without having to scan all the data in
the partition
as with partitioning you should always
try and figure out the types of
questions users will be asking of the
data to decide the keys that you'll use
to cluster
want to learn more about storage
optimization
check out the links below thanks for
tuning in to this episode of bigquery
spotlight
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel on youtube for other great
content
look out for our next episode of
bigquery spotlight and remember
stay curious
[Music]
you